[Música]
qué tal bienvenidos a canadá en las
américas café o el castor cibernético
como también se le conoce este es el
programa de radio canadá internacional
en español del equipo latinoamericano
les habla paloma martínez y estamos
viendo esas imágenes de canadá que
siempre me llama la atención son
lindísima sí son muchos son de todo
grado dios son grandiosos
majestuosa no quiere decir es que no se
refleja en la temperatura hoy estos días
estamos todos un poco decepcionados
porque parece que el verano ya pasó
bueno aquí en el estudio como siempre
leonardo gimeno leonora chama
hola que tal y tenemos dos invitados
especiales cadena vacía que tales
cineasta y también tenemos a juan andrés
arango que también es y nada si nos
vienen a hablar de un proyecto especial
que se llama el set de hornear para gol
o las siete las últimas siete palabras
ya los vamos a contar todo al respecto a
nuestros oyentes que no están nuestros
oyentes o como les decimos siempre se me
olvidan
también escuchan escucha viendo no
escucha viendo porque me suena
y bueno estar comedor internacional para
escuchar a videntes escucha vidente
bueno la idea es que nos atan sigue por
facebook por youtube por el sitio
internet de radio canadá internacional
www.edufinet.com no antes seguir con los
temas del día quiero hablar de los
raptors quien vio el partido ayer yo yo
una parte yo vi en realidad y lewis mail
dos minutos claro de los vilos últimos o
cuartos porque me pone muy nervioso ver
antes de la semana pasada iba ganando
los raptors el último el penúltimo
partido iban ganando por 10 12 puntos y
perdieron por 2 entonces miró realmente
en la definición por uno bueno pero se
ganaron y yo sigo insistiendo que
tuvieron muchísima suerte y todos me
dicen que no jugaron muy bien estamos de
acuerdo es genial fantástico al otro
equipo le faltaban tres de las estrellas
qué pena pero qué alegría me daba la
impresión de que los 23 millones de
habitantes de la ciudad de toronto
estaban en la cara pero viste todos los
diferentes lugares de donde la gente se
reunió en todo canadá para verlas las
imágenes en el fondo dicen que es canadá
el que ganó como país es la primera
venta porque es un equipo de canadá
contra 29 equipos de eeuu antes el único
equipo extranjero en la iv en la
asociación nacional porque me hacía más
asociación nacional que pertenece a la
nación de eeuu o sea un equipo
canadiense en esa asociación de
básquetbol y lo interesante digo siempre
las fechas son a veces a veces son
importantes es ellos obtuvieron la
concesión en 1993 los raptors al igual
que los grises serían vancouver no sé
qué pasó con los grises jan después y
1993 es el último
que canadá un equipo canadiense ganó la
copa stanley en 1993 y en 1900 cuando
cuando nacieron ellos los raptors y 1993
es el último año donde los blue jays de
toronto ganaron el campeonato de béisbol
a nivel nacional así que desde 1993 hoy
se da que se tendría que hacer un
deporte nuevo para que los kanasín
vuelvan a ganar eso es impresionante la
primera vez que un equipo canadiense
gana porque no ha habido muchos
canadienses en esa liga y además es el
hay que recordar que el básquetbol se
inventó en canadá sólo entonces visión
es un y es un deporte que nación es la
que competirá con el hockey sobre hielo
popular había ya ganó entonces yo estoy
súper contenta por los raptors no yo
estoy contento y yo leí un análisis
sobre eso en el que deseen que
justamente que si estaba uniendo a
canadá y que era muy representativo de
lo que era canadá hoy porque vieron a
los fans
los fans eran como de todo tipo
multitudes que se refleja lo que es
canadá también hubiera sido impensable
era el hockey sobre hielo el máximo
deporte canadiense aquí tenemos a un
solo representante canadiense canadiense
entonces sí muy emocionante
muy emocionante por todo por toda la por
todo el país pues su histórico fue
histórico claro que fue histórico lo
interesante de diego también aparte de
eso es la de la gran cobertura que tuvo
en américa latina
estuve viendo un poco los periódicos
desde argentina hasta méxico no hubo un
diario un periódico un programa en
televisión radio que no hablara de este
de este histórico sí y además son las
cosas que me llamó la atención de todo
el proceso digamos antes de que ganaran
el campeonato fue el lema que utilizaron
los raptors calderón
que lo tienen bien utilizando ese tiempo
pero que se hizo súper importante
entonces nosotros
norte y si algo tenemos en común todos
los canadienses
estamos muy nórdicos saltos son el frío
y todo yo tengo un problema existencial
con los warriors porque no me gusta o
dios os en la cancha en este tipo de
deporte no me gusta entonces quién te
gusta yo seguía los andan san antonio el
argentino pero antonio también hay
jugadores groseros seguros no tan
abiertamente
a mí no me gusta lo cierto es que había
una conexión hispana digamos en los
raptors saben que marc gasol él uno de
los de prensa
y este
también jugábamos claro el hermano el
delito y la ganó la nba con los lakers
sabe todo qué bueno que viniste
estudiable ahora a mí me gusta todo si
vas a ratos más me gustaba desde la
época del gran volador
me acuerdo de haber visto y yo dije esto
es un evento histórico sentado frente la
televisión sin entender mucho inglés ya
que el momento viendo cuando jordan
decía en bola abajo el bro el basket
yo dije estos históricos tres meses
es la gran estrella del equipo de los
raptors a kawai leonard lo comparaban
con michael jordan
sí pero no tiene nada que ver para mí no
tiene nada que ver uno con otro y
finalmente esa gran rivalidad que existe
entre montreal y toronto por el hockey
sobre hielo ayer había miles y miles de
montreal en el fútbol en el fútbol el
impacto contra contra el toronto fc
es una pelea muerte pero en el hockey y
en el hockey increíble o sea vida yo
creo que sí y yo creo que si los dos el
equipo de hockey de toronto ganar con
pasta le vamos a salir a todos
de basket de quebec en montreal la cosa
sería diferente
pero a ese nivel o ganar ese campeonato
yo creo que yo estaría orgullosa de ser
canadienne como cielo
los los fanáticos de hockey de toronto
habían salido cuando
cuando los que ganaron la última es lo
que ven
yo soy hincha de san lorenzo en la
argentina y si juega uno de nuestros
enemigos por ejemplo no vamos a ser los
más conocidos pero si juego huracán con
un equipo chileno chileno vamos a
resolver vamos mejor a nuestros
invitados de hoy caben abatían y juan
andrés arango que nos vienen a presentar
un nuevo proyecto que hicieron juntos
pero con otros cineastas con otros cinco
cineastas el proyecto se llama el set de
hernia para solo las últimas siete
palabras es una obra cinematográfica sin
diálogo y con la música de franz joseph
haydn
que además se basa en una de las obras
de este compositor clásico las siete
últimas palabras de cristo en la cruz
por lo que entendí se inspiraron de esa
obra y que sería que a la vez se inspira
de lo que habría dicho jesús en la cruz
que serían como siete frases de dónde
viene la idea cabe porque sé que la idea
original es de usted pero de dónde viene
cómo como decidió digamos abordar este
tema aún de manera cinematográfica y
musical así por desde el principio
hayden de la música de jaén siempre está
ha interpretado en como en catedrales de
manera diferente interesante con las
ventanas cubiertos para que a ella sea
más como obscuro y con una ventana
abierta para que hay una luz exactamente
y bueno para mí es que esos temas d
del perdón y el perdón
en la reunión gracias gracias son
universales no tienen nada que ver con
los cristianos más que los musulmanes o
courel suscrito entonces quería hacer
algo sobre la
la universidad universalidad de esos
temas de una manera
onírico y onírica gracias a que en las
imágenes salen de no del cerebro metro
más del coro software del corazón de
khaled de cada persona como un filtro
del espíritu del high don de jesús o de
cada persona que tiene que enfrentar el
muerte porque porque eso es una cosa que
todos que sean de irak o eeuu
todos tenemos que enfrentar eso y en ese
momento donde tanto polarización entre
la de los países entre las religiones
quería hacer algo sobre las las cosas
que nos unen que no son de la humanidad
finalmente son puros temas humanos
porque si los resumo aquí o si los digo
son el perdón la salvación la relación
el abandono la angustia el triunfo y el
reencuentro que son los siete temas que
se trataron
en la obra de ustedes pero también en la
obra de haydn y que cristo habría dicho
no no sabemos si lo digo y no es tan
importante él tampoco lo dijo
independientemente de que sea cristianos
judíos o musulmanes
son valores son son palabras fuertes
para el ser humano en general
si los dijo bien por él pero no digamos
y bien por los que la escucharon aquel
momento y que rescataron esas palabras
pero presiones de a superinteresante y
poder reunir esas palabras no son como
sentimientos situaciones que todo ser
humano vive en un momento dado en su
vida y que finalmente nadie escapa a la
última etapa que es la muerte que se ve
es como el nacimiento y la vida se ve en
lo que estuve viendo me pareció
magnífico las fotografías son increíbles
las expresiones de la y la música que
esta música
extraordinario mostrando esos rostros
situaciones me gusta muchísimo estamos
viendo que se le está escuchando con la
música no parece que no están poniendo
la música para ver tal vez no se puede
poner la música música podemos poner un
poco de música lo que me llamó la
atención lo que quisiera saber es cómo
hicieron los cineastas cada uno de los
siete cineastas para seleccionar
digamos la palabra que iban a
representar con imágenes cada uno es la
película es otra de las variantes y lo
que sí es en todo el mundo son imágenes
de todo el mundo no sé es que por eso
como hicieron para seleccionar digamos
el lugar la palabra que iban a
representar cada uno y él las imágenes
que iban a poner ahí sí pues en mi caso
no sé si fue siempre así pero en mi caso
fue una invitación que yo recibí de
parte de cada vez de parte de katrin la
productora para hacer una película
dentro de dentro de este proyecto muy
ambicioso sobre esta palabra específica
que ya estaba digamos asignado y al cual
te asignó la mía era madre aquí tu hijo
y
digamos que eso era lo único que te
daban y a partir de ahí había una total
libertad para acercarse a esa palabra
como naturalmente yo como artista la
sentía digamos y para rodarla en el
formato que fuera en el país que fuera
solamente siguiendo en la música de
haydn o sea que había un al hilo rondar
de creatividad enorme y eso fue una cosa
muy liberadora en este proyecto que
permitió como realmente reaccionar de
una manera muy intuitiva y muy natural a
esa energía a esa música tan maravillosa
ya sea idea de esa palabra lo que yo he
visto digamos en producciones de
televisión es que para distintos
capítulos llamarán a un director pero
normalmente digamos la estética que da
es directa a la estética de la
producción que sea en este caso fue
hagan lo que sientan a partir de la base
musical totalmente y yo creo que eso lo
que le da a la película como todo
también esta variedad tan fuerte de
estilos y de puntos de vista personales
que él hacen un viaje súper súper
interesante de seguir y para cada tema
es un
y todos son de acá bueno cada una vive
en quebec pero tenemos un andrés de
colombia tenemos acá bolín monet que es
indígena dialogue y gran y para mí era
muy importante que no sea solamente
bueno blancos quebequenses para que para
para interpretar algo más universal iba
a hablar de las cosas que pasan en todo
el mundo entonces firmamos en haití en
colombia en irán
en quebec en luisiana y eso es algo para
mí que es lo que es la corazón del
humano es la misma donde sea y es un
poco lo que también se ve se vive en
montreal porque eso es lo que vivimos
cotidianamente lo escribimos aquí que
sentimos un poco el origen de todas las
personas que queremos encontramos en la
calle a sus raíces sus culturas pero que
al mismo tiempo todos tenemos cosas en
común
y realmente de alguna manera estoy
haciendo la conexión ahora pero también
tiene que ver con lo que vimos en las
reacciones con respecto a la unión que
creó este evento que es deportivo y que
es comercial y que todo lo que sea pero
que de alguna manera tenemos algo en
común con todos los que estuvieron
viendo el partido de ayer de los rápidos
batalla no muy común hoy un que nos une
a todos ahora que ve cuáles fueron los
desafíos más importantes en la
coordinación de un proyecto tan grande
como este o en la digamos la
fueron varios me imagino si bueno es
difícil el financiamiento porque no es
un cortometraje pero no tampoco es un
largo normal entonces es difícil que los
institución instituciones dan el dinero
fácilmente era súper difícil súper largo
pero también para hacer una película
knight y otro en cuesta tiempo y energía
pero eso era más la productora que 30
años que hizo la management de todo eso
era un trabajo increíble pero hace nueve
años que estamos trabajando en este
proyecto entonces no es como si lo
hicimos de almenara fácil donde se puede
ver empieza empiezan los cines de
montreal hoy
en el marco de que en un fin específico
que yo marqué por acá es por eso es
algún festival especial no va a salir
realmente sale la película sola se en el
cinema dreams de esta noche y yo voy a
estar y mañana en el cinema mundial
y va a estar
finalmente es una película que se puede
ver en cualquier parte del mundo dado
que no hay tampoco palabras en la
película son imágenes y sonidos lenguaje
universal que todo el mundo entiende y
ya fue proyectada la primera proyección
fue en el festival internacional de cine
de rotterdam cierto y después vino el
gran debut quebec cinema
y bueno ya empezaron entonces la
presentación en otros cines aquí en ekin
quebec hay planes para ir al resto de
canadá o afuera de sí esperamos depende
de los festivales que iban a extractarlo
y también lo que yo quiero hacer es es
un cine concierto con el que justifica
tu cuota de 40 el cuarteto y era
diferente y hacerlo como un concierto y
más que una película hay varias maneras
que pueden mostrando a la película en
vivo el concierto las dudas
como las películas mudas carlitos
chaplin estaba la orquesta y pasarela
tendida que interesante ya hicimos una
proyección a segunda de premier privada
en encontrar en una galería de arte con
el cuarteto de que vino de inglaterra
para esa proyección y es una experiencia
debe ser impresionante de ver la música
en vivo debe ser completamente diferente
totalmente última pregunta para ambos
que aprendieron cada uno de ustedes como
cineastas pero también como seres
humanos al hacer su parte de película la
parte que les correspondió no sé
cualquier quien quiere comenzar que fue
lo que fue lo que les dejó este proyecto
para mí era de tener confianza en la
intuición como la las partes que para mi
función
lo mejor en mis películas porque yo hice
como tres son los momentos que es pura
música imagen y no es tanto como yo
quiero hacer es una película pero es más
como una cosa orgánico natural entonces
como sin ponerle tantos tantos filtros
tantos los filtros que sea la música y
el espíritu que sale de yo me dejaste ir
los sentimientos nos guardaste el
raciocinio adentro un poco te muy bien
interesante yo siento algo parecido para
mí esta película es es poesía en
contraposición con otras películas más
narrativas que he hecho que sonaría en
una novela digamos que aquí se pudiera
dejar el aspecto narrativo de un lado y
concentrarse en los sentimientos puros
que esas piezas musicales se transmitía
eso es una experiencia liberadora y
además cómo transferir esa música
maravillosa que hizo hayden a un
contexto radicalmente opuesto como es el
pacífico colombiano donde lloró de la
selva la colombia
afro y ver cómo esa música puede resonar
en ese contexto y transmitir energía en
ese contexto algo muy cómodo interesante
pues a donde filmaste boidron de firma
está en haití y en luisiana y quien
filmó en quebec
carlos máximos en quebec a poner también
en un diario
y canadá
y entonces cada persona podría podría
tomar un lugar o dos lugares o podía
hacerlo como quiera finalmente sí lo es
y como por ejemplo si juana
si hubiera podido firmar en quebec
también no es que o que él es colombiana
entonces tienen que firmar en colombia
esperaba
actualmente que de ver muchos lados de
esa música pero lo importante es que
sale de la persona que el corazón sea
abierta a esa música de esos temas
bueno pues me encanta la metáfora con
respecto a la poesía ya la y a las obras
como narrativas que dotan de otro tipo
de narración porque es verdad que cuando
uno está es hipnótica como decían y se
puede uno adentrar completamente en la
en la película sin un cine sin hacerse
demasiadas preguntas entonces bueno
felicidades por este proyecto entonces
cabe navas bien y juan andrés arango
gracias por haber pasado por nuestros
estudios mucha suerte en el proyecto
que se terminaron o las últimas siete
palabras así que bueno muchas gracias
gracias por estar acá y nos vamos a
poner un vídeo de nuestra aplicación
porque leonardo siempre nos cuenta
[Música]
el vídeo de la aplicación ustedes pueden
ir a las dos tiendas más populares para
los teléfonos de la manzanita y para los
teléfonos de la del robot y pto
[Risas]
que van a traer ese entonces ustedes
pueden ver pueden bajarla a las cinco
lenguas disponibles de radio cara
internacional les sugerimos que bajen
español chino y árabe todavía no en
algún momento suponemos que sí pero
bueno en realidad es porque es mucho más
fácil
yo no puedo leer en chile porque están a
estar las cinco lenguas entonces yendo a
la página de internet de al qanater
nacional en la parte derecha arriba para
encontrar una pequeña imagen donde hacen
clic y ahí tienen el acceso directo para
las tiendas más populares para poder
descargar esta aplicación
gracias lo explicas muy bien pues porque
te lo pido que nos explique por qué lo
haces muy algunos mensajes permiso que
no veo nada
juanjo se nos está mirando el director
de cine juan josé manuel ciría y sé cómo
lo juzgo
ahí está también haciendo fuerza por los
ratos que ya ganaron gustavo lucas lucas
dice me encanta cuando sale
manfred es ecuatoriano
norte y a veces se vuelve a ecuador
bueno y gustavo dice saludos de la
ciudad de melo en uruguay felicitaciones
a los raptors a pesar de no seguir ese
deporte dice la net patricia salazar
rosso hola hola ismael zamora saludos
desde salvatierra guanajuato méxico y
danielle camporini no nos saluda pero
nos está viendo qué bueno que está ahí
daniel porque estaba por presentarles
justamente el vídeo de daniel campo nos
envió un videíto de la semana pasada nos
estuvo escuchando entonces grabó el
momento de la escucha pues y nos muestra
un vídeo me ayuden a ver si lo podemos
escuchar porque se escucha un poquito
ahora hablando se oye bajito pero estás
hablando tú en el vídeo son banderines
onda corta
banderines que nosotros le habremos
enviado en algún momento también porque
son todas las radios internacionales
como tienen
[Música]
muchas gracias
entonces como decíamos al principio
antes de entrar en ondas mucha gente que
no nos dejó de ver de escuchar por onda
corta nos ahí está uno no no es nuestro
muchas maneras argentinas daniel que
está en argentina así que muchas gracias
a danger por seguirnos y bueno
continuamos con el programa porque usted
esta semana tenemos también como siempre
muchísimos mensajes que la gente hace
mucho que no lee más porque siempre
estamos ocupa dificilísimos con las
cosas que pasan aquí en el estudio
tienen ahí por ahí un mensajito si yo
tengo aquí es el inec sordo ni esa línea
de ese es importante proteger la vida de
un ser ya que la vida es única no hay
más un país de humanidad los felicito de
corazón seguir luchando por el bienestar
de los humanos del mundo está comentando
centenares de niños solos piden refugio
en canadá una noticia que hemos
realizado aquí en redacción
yo tengo un correo que es es un
comentario a un artículo sobre artistas
cubanos privados de los servicios
canadienses de inmigración en la habana
es brevemente el tema es que canadá
retiró la mitad del personal en su
embajada en cuba en la habana están
trabajando con siete personas en vez de
14 entonces a raíz de eso decidieron que
la cuestión de las visas para venir a
canadá los cubanos que quieran iniciar
esos trámites que ya los hubieran
iniciado tienen que hacerlo ahora en
mexico
entonces hubo una una reunión de
artistas programadas de una exposición
que estaba programada desde hace tiempo
ya que tenía que llevarse a cabo en
montreal y los artistas cubanos no
pudieron llegar entonces yo hice una
entrevista con un uno de ellos y en base
a eso contesta le bassin
su única es larguísima es muy largo el
artículo pero dice él el arte es algo
que no debe ni tiene que tener fronteras
ni muros porque el arte si es bueno es
universal y son derechos humanos de la
humanidad los cubanos son un pueblo que
han sufrido miles de vejaciones y nada
se suman a estas las autoridades
canadienses es muy largo el ártico pero
ya esto demuestra un poco el sentimiento
de la persona como se llama le vas y vas
o nunca
tampoco bueno yo tengo un mensaje que
comenta algo semejante porque comentaba
un reportaje o una noticia que hicimos
que sí que llevaba por título primer
ministro canadiense y presidente cubano
conversan sobre venezuela y la ley helms
burton y dice será que trudeau cree en
la en las buenas intenciones de un
gobierno comunista de hace más de 50
años que además es amigo del tirano de
maduro es una pregunta entonces eso
comenta no sé quién por qué no dijo su
nombre y no voy a dar su dirección
electrónica no
pero no tenemos aquí el nombre de la
persona muchas gracias
yo aquí tengo un mensaje de que si no me
tapo nos está matando nada a mí le dice
sobre él
el tema propuesta de solución al
problema de escasez de mano de obra
extranjera en canadá dice hola estoy de
acuerdo en que deberían dar la
oportunidad a los colombianos pues en
general puede generar más trabajo y así
no hay tanta pobreza del país ese era el
comenta en el comentario de yanda miller
el último es un sobre un tema hospital
canadiense avanza el tratamiento de
leucemia con un método de enorme
potencial ese es el artículo el título
del artículo escribe
melvin y joel shalit méndez y dice que
necesita ayuda que es de guatemala y que
necesita más información sobre el tema
porque desde hace un año tiene un cáncer
en la sangre eso es un poco el mensaje
que le está mandando bueno generalmente
en los reportajes que preparamos ponemos
información relacionada con los
programas existentes y están
relacionados con otros con otros países
y hay un número de contacto también o
sea informal
a veces no hay nada y simplemente no es
un reportaje sobre el tema
y vio para terminar con los mensajes de
nuestros oyentes tengo aquí un
comentario de alfonso saborio que
comenta el tema captura de caballos
salvajes en calgary iones ese reposo
y la belleza de los caballos en libertad
es incomparable creo que se debe
estudiar otra opción antes de
capturarlos y al menos dejar unos pocos
en el estado natural lo mejor de los
caballitos que vimos en white horse te
acuerdas si se no no en hawai winehouse
en las afueras de washington y se en el
campo si me acuerdo estaban ahí
al aire libre en pleno invierno y si
ahora los porque estaba saturando el
trabajito xenerais hay un reportaje de
hace cinco años cuatro años más o menos
no me acuerdo bien lo que era pero yo sé
que los capturaban a los caballos no los
querían dejar en libertad no sé si era
para preservarlos también nada menos
recuerdo muy bien pero hace mucho tiempo
lo cierto es que en términos de vida
animal y buenas noticias canadá pasó una
ley esta semana para que no se pueda
mantener en cautiverio ni a las ballenas
ni a los delfines ni a ningún otro zetas
mi ballena libre creo que es el primer
país y por lo menos de este hemisferio
en implementar esa política que hay
algunas ciudades en california la ciudad
de méxico y otras ciudades pero países
como país a la letra liberal creo que
canadá es el primero en haber hecho eso
porque dice no podemos más tener
animales en cautiverio para el
entretenimiento humano es
contraproducente porque no lo deja fuera
vienen los los barcos estos
internacionales y se casan la ballena
que lo acabo de dejar afuera para que te
libre que hacemos hay que preservarlos
también si estoy dando un último
comentario para que dejen libre todos
los dinosaurios los raptores porque vaya
ya vamos sin mensajes aquí también en el
campo parquet y oliver dice saludos de
urubichá montreal
magazine hospital de montreal maya sin
debe ser un magazine de salud para todos
daniel campanenses saludos de monroe
alexandra hernández dice saludos para
todos ustedes desde bogotá colombia y
miriam alarcón y se me encanta todas las
cosas que tiene daniel camporini gracias
por compartir yo tengo un bolso una
gorra de radio de la radio y dos remeras
del castor mensajero es tiene mucha
suerte no tengo ninguna hace años años
años que el radio que no está nacional
no nos reparte más en sí y mercadería de
ser de ese estilo pues muchas gracias a
todos que nos puedan seguir comentando
ahora lo que tenemos que hacer es
rápidamente hablar de nuestros temas de
robots y tú vas hablarnos de robots y de
inteligencia artificial si en realidad
no es eso si nos quisieron una firma
interesa y muy importante que hace este
tipo de sondeos de sondeos preguntó a
los trabajadores canadienses obviamente
a una población de trabajadores
canadienses y tenían miedo o no por esta
historia de la automatización y tenían
miedo de perder el puesto de trabajo
gracias
de la inteligencia artificial y de los
robots y parece que los trabajadores
canadienses dicen no me preocupa en
general y los canadienses no los
estadounidenses están como locos con que
la inteligencia artificial el robot van
a robarle todo el trabajo uno pero en
canadá por ejemplo que si están diciendo
hay que tener cuidado cuidado son los
jefes de esos que dijeron que no tenían
problemas también ese es un dato
interesante y lo que también había una
en un estudio que se hizo similar en
eeuu
encontré una palabra que me gustó que
era como los trabajos no tengo acá están
los empleos híbridos que hay eso tenemos
es la tendencia es decir no son
multifuncionales es lo que se hace mucho
aquí nosotros pero uno está muy
acostumbrado a la necesidad de hacer
algo muy particular y que eso me va a
llevar a un trabajo estable claro en
canadá en la especialización es súper
importante y en este caso es la
especialización pero la capacidad de
dejar que
las cosas vengan a uno como por ejemplo
los no sé soy periodista pero entender
el concepto y poder manejar big data por
ejemplo o sea son cosas que no son
compatibles pero exacto o sea tratar de
dice que en la mayor parte de los de los
puestos de trabajo se podría hacer y se
va a tener que hacer para poder tenerlo
o sea la máquina no va a ser todo
tenemos que acoplarnos en la máquina y
la inteligencia artificial para que eso
tenga rinda frutos digamos entonces esa
es la manera el trabajo híbrido es lo
que se viene entonces no se especialicen
más hagan de todo
leonora tú nos presentas tarde ni muy
buen no no juegue no juegue como juegue
premio nobel de la paz el doctor milagro
que fue homenajeada quien aquí en
montreal sí exactamente y me hizo me
hizo acordar un poco hago el lazo con lo
que dijo cabe aquí habló de la
universalidad del tema del perdón
esto creo que este premio nobel que se
le entregó el año pasado al doctor denis
mukwege eso por una vez por un pocas
veces estoy tan de acuerdo con que ese
premio nobel de la paz se le haya
otorgado a este médico que es del congo
y que también se le llama el doctor
milagro porque ayuda a reparar entre
comillas la cirugía reconstructiva
porque aquí se trata de un país donde la
mujer no vale absolutamente nada es
botín de guerra se sabe y se conoce las
violaciones de las mujeres del congo
pero además la destrucción de sus
órganos genitales reproductivos en esa
violación misma y este médico es el que
trata de reconstruir o reparar esos
daños entonces él creó en 1999 un
hospital en el congo que se hizo famoso
y que hoy hoy en día pues en lo que él
dice es que hace hasta 10 operaciones
por día lo cual es una muy mala noticia
me imagino porque sea demasiado
exactamente si él está llevando a cabo
además otra batalla muy fuerte que es
terminar con la impunidad de todos estos
hombres que ya sea de que son de
milicias del ejército en fin que cometen
esos actos que no se pueden innombrables
el lazo que hacía yo un poco con lo que
se dijo aquí es que se le preguntó en
una entrevista que hizo radio canadá y
cómo cómo lograr que eso cambie en el
congo qué es lo que hay que hacer y él
dijo es fundamental la paz y él dijo me
hizo acordar un poco a nelson mandela en
su manera de hablar no y él dijo la paz
se construye diciendo la verdad porque
la verdad es permite establecer una
verdadera relación entre las personas
entre las comunidades y también permite
avanzar sobre el camino del perdón de la
reconciliación y de tener una visión
común si no decimos la verdad es el odio
que ocupa el lugar entonces eso es un
personaje
increíble y el doctor
ya había estado aquí en invitado por la
universidad de manitoba
pero esto hace diez años había recibido
un doctor honoris causa de la
universidad de winnipeg y esta vez
recibió el mismo homenaje en la
universidad de montreal con lo cual
además firmó acuerdos con cinco
facultades de medicina diferentes áreas
psicología y entera con la universidad
de montreal para trabajar juntos en el
hospital donde él está trabajando en el
congo así que saludo a este señor porque
es increíble el trabajo que está
haciendo con las mujeres y sobre todo el
habla mucho de la ayuda psicológica dice
que es fundamental en esto entonces
bueno es un tema que me interesó a mí
esta semana y lo pueden encontrar tanto
el reportaje de leonardo que va a estar
en línea a partir de mañana temprano en
la mañana sábado mañana sábado temprano
en www.sprint.com o el reportaje de
leonora también se encontrará ahí y
siguiendo los temas médicos pablo que no
pudo venir hoy acá esta semana destaca
un tema que él estuvo atrás
y nos cuenta que hay una escasez o que
va a haber muy pronto una escasez de
médicos geriatras en la provincia de
québec entonces que hay un problema
digamos que es social porque hay que
encontrar una solución rápidamente a
cómo van esas trayendo de la pueblo
[ __ ] en las faldas poblaciones o
envejecidos sí y la gente va a necesitar
cada vez más médicos que puedan
especializarse en este caso se
especialicen se ven en las personas
mayores en geriatría entonces nos
cuentan los informes nos habla de un
informe del instituto nacional de salud
pública de quebec que lanza una señal de
alarma para que los jóvenes que están
interesados en en esa área de la
medicina lo piensen bien porque todas
las sociedades están envejeciendo y lo
que lo que pasa en quebec pasa en el
resto de canadá y en el resto del mundo
porque incluso en los países en vías de
desarrollo como se les llama también
están teniendo problemas en cuanto al
envejecimiento de la población entonces
pablo nos presenta ese reportaje y el
mío
él me oyó esta semana hablé con un líder
sindical mexicano que estuvo de paso por
montreal es un su nombre es benedicto
martínez orozco y él se vino vino a
formar parte de un congreso un congreso
de la csn que es la congregación de
sindicatos nacionales de aquí de quebec
y lo interesante es que él representa a
dos sindicatos mexicanos dos sindicatos
independientes completamente alejados de
los sindicatos tradicionalmente ligados
digamos al poder en méxico y entonces él
nos contó como en realidad hay que
recordar un poco que durante las
negociaciones del tratado de libre
comercio de américa del norte el nuevo
digamos uno de los sindicalistas y el
sindicato más grande de canadá estuvo
diciendo las condiciones de trabajo de
los trabajadores en méxico tienen que
cambiar para que el tratado sea más
equitativo si los trabajadores en méxico
están mal pagados en canadá ni en eeuu
nadie se beneficia a la gente el pueblo
los trabajadores nos queden por eso
también vienen tantos trabajadores al
norte
y nos vio en los salares y los
beneficios se quedarían en sus lugares
contentos exactamente entonces explicaba
eso el representante de un informe de
siete días y entonces hablando con él
benedicto martínez orozco nos dimos
cuenta que las relaciones entre los
sindicalistas de los tres países de
américa del norte son muy fuertes tienen
hay muchas consagró inducción
exactamente y las condiciones de trabajo
en los tres países son muy similares
contrario lo que uno podría pensar
entonces muy interesante esta
conversación que tuve con benedicto
martínez o la escuela dividí en
pedacitos porque solamente le busca
escuchar pedacitos y si no también
pueden escucharla completo en el sitio
internet donde determinado ya falta de
dos minutos nada más
miriam alarcón nos dice me enteré que el
ministro de cultura de canadá tiene
origen tucumano o al menos sus padres es
así que nació en tucumán y sigo aquí a
la edad de 8 años
un poquito más chicos ocho años sus
hermanas tenían seis y cuatro ok
y al ladito y mercedes alaya dice bueno
recuerdo muchos oyentes de radio grada
en onda corta cuando transmitieron
unidos con radio nederland en el casto
mensajero igualmente tengo muchos
recuerdos de vuestra radio y en todo en
todo el mundo saludos desde chilenos
dice mercedes chiles muy bien bueno pues
entonces mensajes de todos nuestros
oyentes una última vuelta que bueno que
se quedaron gracias por habernos
acompañado espero que les haya gustado
nuestro programa hay muchos temas
interesantes y en realidad todos los
temas estaban relacionados porque todo
alguna manera había una escuálida de
conexión y entonces entonces caben a
bastian juan andrés arango leonard a
chapman leonardo gimeno
martín es nos despedimos muchas gracias
por haberlo acompañado y será hasta la
próxima 40 que nos pueden seguir por
facebook triples por facebook o por
nuestro sitio internet oriol w punto etc
y netbooks punto sea y en el sitio en
ese y canadá en las américas en facebook
y youtube bueno por todos lados
kabul hay y whitfield y benoit rioja
muchas gracias me ha sido un placer
trabajar con ellos saga o gracias a dios